People who are cynical about religious
structures like to think of faith as the
willingness to demolish your intellect
in the service of superstition and you
know,
there's,
there's something to be said for that
perspective,
but not a lot because the reality is
much more sophisticated.
Part of the faith that's,
that is being insisted upon in the old
testament is something like,
and I'm speaking psychologically here
again,
that it's useful.
Deposit A.
Hi.
Good to aim at it.
So,
and I,
I really think that's practically useful
to the research we've done with the
future authoring program,
for example,
indicates pretty clearly that if you get
people to conceptualize an ideal and a
unbalanced ideal,
you know,
so what do you want for your family?
What do you want for your career?
What do you want for your education?
What do you want for your character
development?
How are you going to use your time
outside of work?
How are you going to structure your use
of drugs and alcohol and places where
you might get impulsive?
How can you avoid falling into a
horrible path?
If you really think that through and you
come up with an integrated ideal and
you,
you put it above us,
something to reach for,
then you're more committed to the world
in a positive way and you're less
tormented by anxiety and uncertainty and
so and that makes sense,
right?
Because here you are alive and
everything,
and so unless you were Cape,
if you're not capable of manifesting
some positive relationship with the fact
of your being,
then how could that be anything other
than hellish because it would just be
anxiety provoking and terrible because
you're vulnerable and there'd be nothing
useful or worthwhile to do.
Well,
that's just not.
I just can't see that as a winning
strategy for anyone.
You can make a rational case for
adopting that strategy in that,
you know,
you can say,
well,
there's no evidence for for a
transcendent morality or for an ultimate
meaning.
There's no hard empirical evidence,
but it seems to me that there's
existential evidence as well that has to
be taken into account and of course like
psychologists have talked about this a
lot.
I'm Carl Rogers,
for example,
in [inaudible] for that matter.
Freud for that matter,
most of the great psychologists have
pointed out that you know,
you can derive reasonable information
that's solid from your own experience,
especially if you also talk to other
people and you can kind of see in your
own life when you're on a productive
path that sort of ennobles and
enlightens you or a destructive path.
And I think it's kind of useful to think
that maybe the dichotomy between those
two paths might be real,
you know,
and,
and because that also allows you to give
credence to your intuitions about that
sort of thing.
But I don't anyways,
I don't think it's unreasonable to pause
it.
That since you're alive,
adopting the highest possible regard for
the fact that you're alive and you're
surrounded by other creatures that are
alive.
I just can't see how that can possibly
be construed as a losing strategy.
And so that's the first.
So that's something like faith,
right?
It's faith,
it's not,
it's not only faith in your being,
but it's faith in being as such.
And the faith would be something like,
if you could orient your being properly,
then maybe that would orient you with
being as such.
And you never know.
Like,
I mean it might be true.
There's no reason to assume that it
wouldn't be true.
I mean,
even if you just take a strict
biological perspective on this and think
about us as the product of three and a
half billion years of evolution.
I mean we have struggled over all those
billions of years to be alive and to
match ourselves with reality.
And so because one of the things I've
often wondered is,
you know,
life is definitely difficult.
There's no doubt about that.
And it's unfair and there's inequality
and all of those things and people are
subject to all sorts of terrible things.
But I also wonder if you weren't
actively striving to make things worse,
just how much better could they be?
You know,
because people are very,
they're like houses that are divided
amongst themselves.
They're pointing in six different
directions at the same time.
They're working at cross purposes to
themselves because of bitterness and
resentment and an what unprocessed
memories and childhood hatreds and
unexamined assumptions,
all sorts of things,
and you,
you just gotta wonder if you could push
that aside and orient yourself properly.
And then the other thing that of course
is stressed very heavily in the old
testament and of course that goes
through the entire biblical corpus is
that it's not only enough to establish a
positive relationship with being,
which I think is the essential.
It's a good description of faith.
You have to make that decision,
right?
Because being is very ambivalent and you
can make the case that maybe it's
something that should have never
happened,
but that doesn't seem to be productive
to me.
And faith seems to be.
I'm going to act as if being is
ultimately justifiable and that if I
partake in it properly,
I will improve it rather than making it
worse.
So I think that's the statement of
faith.
And then what seems to go along with
that is something like truth in
conception,
inaction.
You know,
even people like Jacob who are pretty
damn morally ambivalent to begin with,
get hammered a lot by what they go
through and what seems to happen is that
they're hammered into some sort of
ethical shape,
right?
So by the mid point of their life's
journey,
there are people who are solidly planted
who you can trust and who don't betray
being or themselves or their fellow
Matt.
And so it's an interesting.
I mean it seems reasonable to me to
first assume that you have establish a
relationship with something that's
transcendent.
It might even be just the future version
of you and then second that you have to
align yourself with reality in a
truthful manner and that that's your
best bet and the biblical stories at
Roxbury.
Quite realistic about that too because
they don't really say that if you do
that,
you're going to be instantly transported
to the promised land.
Like even Moses,
as we'll find out in the accident
stories,
he never makes it to the promised land.
And so it's not like you're offered
instantaneous,
final redemption.
If you move out forthrightly into the
world,
establish a faithful relationship with
being an attempt to conduct yourself
with integrity,
but it's your best bet and it might be
good enough,
and even if it's not good enough,
it's really preferable to the
alternative,
which seems to be something closely akin
to hail,
both personal and social.